Greg Gage : Qui n'aimerait pas cartonner en géographie,
réussir à placer tous les pays sur une carte
ou éviter les situations gênantes où on oublie le prénom
de la personne en face.
Il se trouve que notre mémoire, comme d'autres muscles du corps,
peut être renforcée et améliorée.
Mais au lieu d'étudier avec des fiches,
il pourrait y avoir un moyen de pirater notre mémoire
pendant le sommeil.
(Musique)
Pourquoi dort-on ?
On se pose cette question depuis les débuts de la civilisation.
Bien que nous n'ayons pas de réponse exacte,
des théories expliquent pourquoi nous en avons besoin.
Pendant le sommeil,
le cerveau transforme les souvenirs à court terme de la journée
en souvenirs à long terme.
C'est la « consolidation de la mémoire »
et c'est cette théorie qui pousse les scientifiques à se demander
si nous pouvons choisir quels souvenirs améliorer.
Selon un récent article de Ken Paller et ses collègues de Northwestern,
cela pourrait être possible,
et ça a piqué notre curiosité.
Joud a réalisé sa propre expérience
pour vérifier si la mémoire est améliorée en écoutant des sons en dormant.
Joud, comment testes-tu si nos souvenirs s'améliorent grâce au sommeil ?
Joud Mar'i : Il nous faut un sujet humain.
[Étape 1. Jouer à un jeu]
On utilise un jeu de mémoire sur iPad.
On fait jouer notre sujet à ce jeu ;
il doit se rappeler des images et leurs emplacements.
GG : Comme un jeu de mémoire pour enfants,
on doit deviner où est l'image.
Et on associe chaque image à un son qui la représente.
JM : Si vous voyez, par exemple, une image de voiture,
vous entendrez un bruit de moteur.
(Moteur de voiture qui démarre)
GG : Juste avant de dormir, on va vous tester.
On va voir si vous vous rappelez où sont placées les images.
Quand vous verrez une image, vous entendrez un son.
L'expérience commence.
Vous allez faire une sieste.
Pendant votre sommeil, on mesure votre activité cérébrale.
JM : On attend alors que vous atteignez le sommeil lent,
la phase de sommeil la plus profonde, où il est difficile de vous réveiller.
GG : OK, pause.
Quelques informations sur le sommeil.
Il y a quatre phases : le sommeil léger, le sommeil paradoxal,
mais nous allons nous intéresser au sommeil lent.
Il tire son nom des signaux électriques, les ondes delta,
produites par le cerveau.
C'est le moment où, selon les scientifiques,
la mémoire peut se consolider.
Pendant le sommeil profond,
on va faire quelque chose sans que vous sachiez.
C'est le moment délicat, on fait écouter les sons
(Moteur qui démarre)
GG : Tous les sons ?
JM : Non, seulement la moitié pour voir s'il y a une différence.
GG : Donc votre hypothèse,
c'est que les sons entendus en dormant,
on s'en rappelle mieux.
JM : Oui, exactement.
GG : Quand on se réveille et qu'on joue au jeu,
on réussit mieux ou moins bien qu'avant la sieste ?
Ce dont on s'aperçoit, est que si l'on entend le son durant notre sommeil
par exemple une voiture,
on se souviendra où est placée la voiture
à notre réveil.
Mais si on n'entend pas le son pendant le sommeil,
par exemple, une guitare,
on a moins de chances de s'en souvenir au réveil.
Les images liées à des sons ont été mieux mémorisées
que celles qui ne l'étaient pas,
même s'il ne se souvient pas avoir entendu ces sons ?
JM : Oui, on demande.
GG : On sait qu'il dort, qu'il n'entend rien,
et au réveil, il réussit mieux avec ces images-là.
JM : C'est de la magie.
GG : Joud a testé 12 sujets et a obtenu des résultats significatifs.
Ce n'est pas que vous vous souvenez mieux, mais que vous oubliez moins.
Je ne pensais vraiment pas qu'on pouvait s'améliorer à un test de mémoire
juste en écoutant des sons en dormant,
mais on a reproduit ces expériences.
Les souvenirs accumulés pendant la journée sont très fragiles,
et ils sont facilement oubliés.
En les réactivant pendant qu'on dort, sans en avoir conscience,
on aurait moins de chances de les oublier.
C'est incroyable.
Nos cerveaux fonctionnent, même quand nous nous reposons.
Si vous êtes comme moi et distrait,
peut-être qu'il vous faut une paire d'écouteurs et un canapé.